GOOD THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR
MAY TWO EIGHTH TWENTY IS YOUR
CALLED. PLEASE BE ADVISED ON
ALL AND RECORD OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS BEEN MADE AND HAS
ALSO BE TELEPHONE. MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC ATTENDED THIS TURN
WHERE MY AT ALL. AND COMPLY
WITH GUIDANCE ON FIZZ DISTANCE.
A MUST ALSO FROM CONDO THAT
THIS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDE ORDERING THE HEARING.
VIOLATION OF THESE RULES WHICH-
OF TO REMOVE OR AND FOR
SURPRISE. AMID SECTOR PROVED
THE ROLL. COOLEY WHERE CAN I.
THAT FLORA GIPSON HERE LATE
YEAH MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS. RAMOS
RUBIO. VIEW PUT OFF YOUR- WEBER.
WELCOME WE HAVE A WE ARE
CONSIDER SO BECAUSE IT MOVER
MISTER- AFTER SECOND OF I
MISTER MISTER SECTOR PLEASE
CALL ROLL. COOLEY I GREW AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I'VE
BEEN. BENNETT HI FLORA GIVES-
GIPSON AYE. LEAVE I. MATHIS
MATHIS HI RAMOS RUBIO. RUBIO
HIVE YOU PUT. THE FOOD WHILE I.